Trascrizione: Alessio Fresca
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Vi sto chiedendo, per alzata di mano:
quanti di voi, negli ultimi dieci anni,
hanno pensato di lasciare tutto
e trasferirsi all'estero?
Beh, potreste essere sorpresi dal fatto
che nell'ultimo decennio
sono sempre di più
le persone che viaggiano
per periodi prolungati
con l'obiettivo di sperimentare
nuove vite, o periodi di vita,
in altri luoghi del mondo.
Sono forse sempre meno le persone
che prendono tre giorni di vacanza;
ma invece sempre di più le persone
che incominciano
a lavorare in smartworking,
e dicono: perché no?
Perché non posso incominciare a lavorare
da un posto che non sia casa?
Perché magari devo mantenere un affitto
in una città costosissima come Milano,
come Amsterdam, come Londra,
quando posso spendere gli stessi soldi
e andare a stare in un Airbnb
in Sud Italia, in Portogallo,
o in Costa Rica,
o in altri luoghi del mondo
dove posso spendere molto meno,
vivere esperienze diverse
e magari addirittura vivere
una qualità di vita migliore,
rispetto a quella precedente?
"La qualità della nostra vita
è definita dalla somma dei ricordi
e delle esperienze che abbiamo vissuto."
Questa è una citazione
in cui mi sono sempre trovato.
Infatti per me viaggiare,
conoscere nuove persone,
esplorare nuovi luoghi
è sempre stata la ricetta
per il mio entusiasmo,
per la mia soddisfazione,
per la mia felicità.
Ed è proprio per questo
che qualche anno fa,
nell'ormai lontano 2019,
dopo aver lasciato
il posto di lavoro fisso,
ho fondato la mia start up
e ho deciso di lasciarmi
tutto alle spalle,
di non avere più una casa.
Ho dunque lasciato la città in cui vivevo
da più di quattro anni - Amsterdam -
e ho deciso di non avere più
una dimora fissa, una dimora stabile
e per qualche mese ho continuato a vivere,
e viaggiare, come nomade digitale.
Alla fine dei conti,
la mia esperienza allora
è stata tanto intensa quanto breve.
Infatti, il mio viaggio allora è finito
con l'avvento del Covid.
Ma è proprio in quel momento
che ho momentaneamente smesso
di viaggiare nel mondo fisico,
e come tanti altri, ho incominciato
a immergermi sempre di più
in quello che possiamo definire
un mondo digitale.
Ma come vi sentireste,
se vi dicessi che sono già,
ormai, più di 20 anni
che viviamo in un mondo che è,
per l'appunto, in parte digitale?
Le persone nate, come me, negli anni '90
lo conoscono molto bene
questo mondo, questo universo digitale,
in quanto siamo noi stessi
la prima generazione di nativi digitali.
Siamo la prima generazione
che non ha solo imparato
dai libri di scuola,
ma anche dai tutorial di YouTube.
Siamo la prima generazione
che è passata dal giocare fuori,
all'aria aperta,
con gli amici, al parchetto sotto casa,
al connettersi online,
su consolle o su computer,
per giocare con perfetti sconosciuti
dall'altra parte del mondo.
Siamo la prima generazione
che ha cercato persone affini a noi
prima online,
e solo successivamente
le ha incontrate poi in vita reale.
Insomma, pensate a come
l'avvento della tecnologia
abbia a tutti gli effetti rivoluzionato
la vita di tutti i giorni.
Per esempio la mattina, svegliandoci,
la prima cosa che facciamo
è guardare il telefono.
La maggior parte di noi, poi,
passa le successive 8-10 ore
a lavorare davanti a un monitor.
La sera, non contenti,
magari torniamo a casa
e accendiamo la televisione
per informarci o per intrattenerci.
La digitalizzazione
della vita di tutti i giorni
è quindi ormai inevitabile,
e tutti ne parlano;
ma solo il 25% degli italiani sa cosa sia.
Sto parlando del Metaverso.
Questo neologismo deriva
dalla science fiction degli anni 90.
Infatti, la sua prima apparizione
risale al romanzo di fantascienza
"Snow Crash", di Neal Stephenson,
del 1992.
La parola metaverso
è frutto dell'unione di "meta",
termine di origine greca
che ha acquisito il valore di "trans",
ed "universo".
Il Metaverso, però,
è un concetto in divenire,
che non è ancora nato ma fa già rumore.
Pensiamo, solamente, all'evoluzione
e all'avvento dell'internet stesso.
Il primo Internet, quello degli anni 90,
viene chiamato Web 1.0;
ed è basato su contenuti statici
come i primi siti internet,
i primi siti blog,
i primi motori di ricerca.
Il secondo Internet,
quello dei giorni nostri,
è nato negli anni 2000
e viene invece chiamato "Web 2.0".
Questo è basato
sull'interazione tra utenti
che avviene tramite i social network
e le varie applicazioni
che possiamo trovare online.
Se quindi il primo Internet
si basa sul concetto di informazione,
ed il secondo Internet
si basa sul concetto di interazione,
allora l'Internet del futuro
si baserà sul concetto di partecipazione.
Ed è proprio in questo momento,
che il Metaverso entra in gioco.
Immaginate quindi il Metaverso
come un grande universo digitale
interattivo ed immersivo,
una vera e propria
estensione virtuale del mondo reale,
in cui ogni cittadino,
tramite visori 3D o altri dispositivi,
è rappresentato da un avatar.
Mondo reale e mondo virtuale
entrano in contatto
per creare un'esperienza
personalizzata, immersiva
e dall'alto tasso di coinvolgimento.
L'obiettivo è un vero e proprio ibrido
tra fisico e virtuale,
ormai sempre più indistinguibili.
Il Metaverso, però, non si limiterà
a una singola esperienza:
è pervasivo, e toccherà quasi tutti
gli aspetti della vita umana.
La persistenza, quindi, sarà
la caratteristica chiave del Metaverso,
che offrirà e garantirà
una continuità di esistenza.
La vita nel Metaverso
non si interromperà nel momento in cui
non indosseremo gli occhiali 3D,
oppure una tuta smart.
Non ci sarà un interruttore on e off.
Inoltre, non sarà previsto
alcun ripristino.
Ogni azione avrà una conseguenza,
e non sarà possibile tornare indietro.
La vita nel Metaverso non verrà
resettata come in un videogioco.
Le azioni e i comportamenti di ogni utente
avranno quindi un vero e proprio effetto,
un impatto sulla vita di tutti gli altri.
Ed è proprio nel Metaverso
che si evolverà il concetto
di socializzazione virtuale
che al giorno d'oggi attribuiamo
alle interazioni sui social.
Non avremo solo a che fare con una rete
più o meno estesa di contatti,
ma ci approcceremo con persone
da tutto il mondo
che potremo vedere in tre dimensioni
come se fossero in carne ed ossa.
Il Metaverso, dunque,
potrebbe diventare
il tassello fondamentale
per permettere a questa nuova era
di Internet, il Web 3.0,
di concretizzarsi.
In conclusione,
stiamo attraversando un momento storico
dal punto di vista tecnologico,
che sta rivoluzionando il concetto
di "Home", di casa.
Prima siamo partiti
da una continua espansione
del e nel mondo fisico
tramite l'apertura dei confini,
il viaggiare e il trasferirsi all'estero.
Poi, a causa del Covid, abbiamo vissuto
una vera e propria implosione,
una quarantena che ha limitato
i nostri confini, e ha ridefinito casa.
Espansione prima, implosione dopo,
potranno solo che portare
ad una futura esplosione, un Big Bang,
una vera e propria transizione
dal mondo fisico di tutti i giorni
ad un mondo virtuale, digitale,
senza limiti e senza confini.
Questo è il Metaverso.
(Applausi)